let's jump over to the story here we go
everybody from timcast.com SNL staff
writers boycotting this weekend's
episode over Dave Chappelle hosting
according to report there you go that's
about it they're not going to do the
show an unnamed Insider told the outlet
but none of the actors are boycotting so
the uh they say quote the room was full
of writers they all pitched ideas and
they seemed very excited about it Dave
is looking to have some fun so
there uh that was a rep from uh
Chappelle saying there's nothing going
on but uh I don't know what do you guys
think they want they want to try and
cancel Dave Chappelle well this story
first came from anonymous source that
that again came out didn't reveal who or
she uh was and said oh we're going to be
boycotting
um Dave Chappelle and his staff are
saying hey we've been working with the
writers and the actors for the last
three days nothing's changed no one's
really boycotting us so I think this is
just like the kind of Netflix protest
that we saw of Dave Chappelle where the
media was hyping it up